So designing tables is hard.
I was not prepared for that.
Did you notice
that this data set,
it's got tons of
missing stuff in it?
Oh.
All through it?
It's like looking around,
is there any data around?
I'm just seeing a
NAs wherever I look.
It's like I'm in a world of
NAs when I look at this data.
But you got some good stuff
here, the stuff that's not NA.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I don't think
you're ready for this.
I think I'm ready.
Well--
It looks really good.
I can read the code, so.
What?
This is looking great.
So it took me a while
to get to, like you said,
what is the data?
Is there data here?
And how do I put it in a table?
Yes.
And I definitely
approached this of like, oh,
I use the tidyverse.
So my data should be tidy.
And then my first table
was just one long column.
And I was like, oh--
Yeah, yeah, it's
a common mistake.
You don't want to be
tidying the tables.
If your table is
too long, you're not--
it's not useful.
Yeah, exactly.
And it should be--
it's almost like you're
reading in a way.
You're going to make it ready
for reading and for a person
to read, not for a computer to
read, if that makes any sense.
I think it makes sense.
But this is great.
How do you choose the colors?
OK.
It's always a
hard thing for me.
I was like experimenting
with a million colors,
and I just don't--
I can never settle on stuff.
So this was the process.
So I decided I was going to
look at tax status of California
newspapers.
And then I was like,
California makes
me think of summer, the beach,
and the vapor wave aesthetic.
OK, that's just saying
that these are pretty big,
wavy colors like salmon.
You get the blue, so turquoise.
Yeah, so I--
I'm digging it.
--went in, and I was like--
so I looked for
vapor wave palettes.
Basically, I pulled a color
palette, and I used that.
And then what I really liked
about the color palette
is with the scales code here.
So when I was doing-- when I
was using this for the color
palette, you give it your--
I don't know-- your markers.
Like, here are my
favorite colors.
But then because it is
interpolating, I guess,
or interpreting--
It isn't-- it actually
is interpolating.
So they been-- yeah, just
like in the graphics editor,
those are the marks, the
interpolation points,
I guess, you can
say, your color.
Yeah, so it was great.
Because when I
first got the table
and I got the columns
color, I was like,
oh, this is so much better
than just the palette
because I'm getting that range.
So then what I did is I went
in, and I used a color picker
in the browser to take--
I think it's like
this color here.
And then I set the alpha
to be really light.
Because it looked funny.
The white wasn't a right
color for the background.
And then what was really cool--
I mean, I learned
so much doing this.
But being able to
target all of my NAs
and have a specific function
to turn anything that was an NA
a specific color was
really, really cool.
Because it was like--
It is cool.
--now, it's like my
NAs match the background,
and it's not gray.
It's not like-- I mean,
this is a jarring table.
This red is atrocious.
I like it.
I like it too, but it's not--
to critique my own table, the
colors aren't informative.
Like 1977 is not a
dangerous number.
It doesn't need to be
very red compared--
It's just like the '70s.
It should be like purple-blue
or something like that.
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, like so--
Provocative of the decade.
Yeah, I may be reversing
the color palette or things
like that.
But what I thought--
what I took away from this
was how you can actually
surgically select colors in GT.
And that was what I think
seemed like it would be really
challenging and was probably--
I think it was probably the
easiest thing I did was just--
well, besides laying the pipe
GT was like, oh, I want to--
as long as you know what
something is called,
you can target it with
a color, which was--
Yes, exactly.
--super cool.
And you can see
the code for that.
So I think the
color did one thing,
but you did also-- if, OK,
see different columns, right?
Yeah.
Years of operation,
year founded--
green.
Yeah, it's kind of neat.
Because, I guess,
you have to do it
that way because there's
different domains, right?
Yeah.
If you did it
all togetger, it'd
be sort of messed up because
the data is different.
So that was fun.
So that was where the font
came from was because--
Oh, it's a Goggle font, OK.
It's a Google font.
So I was like, I don't want to
deal with downloading fonts.
I don't want to wait
for a font today.
Use the fonts you have.
So I was like, well--
This is nice because everybody
can use this font, right?
Yes, yes.
As long as you have internet
access, it's super simple.
Yes, as long as you
have internet access,
you too can use
this incredible--
I mean--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Just have internet, please.
I feel like you do a really
good job with footnotes
and source notes.
And I just wanted to try them.
Yes, try them.
So--
If they don't work,
then at least you tried.
I tried.
This is pretty good,
though, because you
don't have a huge, huge table.
So you can get to the bottom
without scrolling forever.
And it was just like--
I bet that-- yeah.
--this is missing data.
Yeah.
I think that's good.
So it wasn't even
super hopeful, but yeah.
And then, because of
the calls we've done,
I was like, I can use markdown.
So I was
Yeah.
Marldown is awesome
in these tables.
Look at that.
You just put in some
links and stuff--
Yeah.
--which is great.
Put in some links.
I was like, yeah,
let's get wild here.
But it was one of those
things where GT, I think,
is deceptively simple.
Because sitting
down to do this, I
was like, oh, I'll be
able to knock this out
in 20, 30 minutes.
And then I was like--
You could, but--
You could.
--it wouldn't be like this.
It wouldn't be like this.
You wouldn't get this far.
Yeah.
So it was really interesting.
And just-- we've
talked a little bit
about preparing your data
for a graph or a plot
is different from a table.
But also, then I was
like, what would even
be interesting for a table?
Because a table,
you're not necessarily
creating a table for the
same purpose as a plot.
I don't want to
average everything
and only have six rows.
I mean, you have tables where
you want that, but I was like,
no, this would be an overview.
So how granular do
you get with the data?
Yeah, it's almost like
it has the same number
of considerations, but
they're totally different.
Yes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So we have links.
They're nicely styled.
Check out these underlines.
It's not right below the text.
It's a little bit further down.
I like nice links.
It's also colored in a
way which is not defaulty.
Because who wants defaulty?
So I'm going to click on it,
and it opens in another tab.
Check that out.
And it faithfully opens up.
So this is like a little catalog
for these cool [INAUDIBLE]
that people have been
looking at in this data set.
[INAUDIBLE]
Wait, so what I'm
missing is you're
going from that
nice summary table,
and now, we're scrolling down.
Can you go through
that real quick?
Can you show me again?
How does this work?
The trick, having a frozen
header and a frozen footer--
Yeah.
--is to make multiple tables--
three tables, to be exact.
It sounds nuts.
But that's the only
way you can do it
because every other way
is prone to failure.
So these are multiple tables?
Yes, sort of globbed
together with HTML tools.
So there's a div here.
There's a div here,
another div, another div.
So it's three divs within a div.
But yeah, this middle div
is basically the body.
And I've hidden the home labels.
You can totally do that.
[INAUDIBLE] isn't it?
Another option is
to have options
just like call
labels hidden, true,
and then it's [INAUDIBLE].
The only major thing
you have to do,
and this is super,
super important, is you
have to set the widths of each
column in each of these tables.
Otherwise, it just fails.
You just get misaligned
stuff, and it'll just
look horribly bad.
But that said, this is a pretty
simple table besides that,
but I did a lot of prep stuff.
So I ran the table.
That's no big deal.
I put that in one file because
I didn't want to see this again.
So it just sourced [INAUDIBLE].
Fine.
Another kind of
cool thing I did is
there's lots of different places
that these papers come from,
or publications.
So I went to the census
page, and I tried
to have groups of students.
So I figured, had to have
some sort of groupings.
So I did this, West,
Midwest, South, Northeast,
Canada-- because there's
Canadian stuff in there, too.
And these are maybe
dubious groupings
because some people say that
these are not [INAUDIBLE]..
But that's what I found
in this publication,
so I'm just sticking with it.
So I have all these states.
And the cool thing I wanted
to do is, if you notice here,
I wanted to group them together.
Otherwise, they'd just
be all over the place.
I wanted it to be
in a certain cluster
of the same publications,
or publications
within a certain state within
a group, which is South,
Midwest, so on and so forth.
First of all, all the URLs,
they didn't look so great.
Yeah.
I didn't even-- some
of them didn't even work.
I went through a process
of just checking each URL.
I made this
function, isValidUrl.
So basically, I'm just--
and it takes a long time,
understandably because there's
lots of these, and it
has to check each one
and make sure it returns a 200.
So I check all these, and then
I just filter, and I say OK.
I do this.
It takes 20 minutes,
super-long time.
That just went away.
And then I just started
[INAUDIBLE] file, read it
back again.
It's like a checkpoint.
Never have to do it again.
And then I do a bunch of link
cleaning, get rid of the HTTPS.
Get rid of some other cruft
that's all over the place.
Some of these links lead to
donation pages or contact pages
or Abouts.
It's like, just give
me the base URL.
So I was pretty careful
with my [INAUDIBLE] here.
Just get rid of stuff that
was safe to get rid of.
And then yeah,
about your range--
these factor to make sure
that these states were
all in the same order as
here, and then yeah, I just
capitalized a few things.
Make sure it looks nice.
Change a few things--
For Profit just to FP.
I like the short forms.
It fits nicely.
And then yeah, languages--
I noticed there was some
inconsistencies there.
I just cleaned it up to either
EN or ES, and I made the table.
So I made the links,
obviously, right here.
No, like this.
I used publication name,
the cleaned up URL.
I made a pattern that
made the link from HTML.
If you use calls merge,
and you make a pattern,
this is unescaped, so
you could basically
use this as HTML that appears.
It's a little bit of a
loophole, but I'll take it.
So basically, this is column 1.
This is column 2.
Repeat column 2 again because
we're just taking the link
and making sure it works.
It's like an anchor tag.
So that's great.
And calls label-- got to
have it to do this stuff.
Super important
if you want to do
this sort of table, which has
tons of content and other table
bits around it.
You just set the widths of
each [INAUDIBLE] column.
As long as you have a
few columns, [INAUDIBLE]
everything, you're
guaranteed to have
everything set with the width.
So it doesn't change
with the content.
It's basically what
you don't want.
I use lots of these opt
functions, as you do as well.
All caps for getting
this cool lookaround.
Some of these names
are super long.
So what I've done was I've
targeted a bunch of these
that had lots of characters.
I just guessed.
I just picked this
number, and basically,
if the number of
characters is beyond 30,
we'll just change
letter spacing,
make it a bit more tight.
This is like trimming, but not
official trimming for the font.
It's basically like, this
works on every single font.
Same with the URL.
Those are even
longer in some cases,
even though it's smaller.
So I cut off 75.
I made even tighter
in some cases.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE] there.
And I even fooled around
a bit with some CSS.
This is how I changed the
links to be just a bit less
defaulty and a bit nicer.
I just changed the
color to be dark cyan.
And this really hard
to find parameter text
underline position under.
This makes it so this
line, the link underline,
is a little bit further
away from the text.
That looks nicer.
I like that.
This is publication ready.
You could put this
in a Shiny app.
I think I could, and I could
probably get away with it, too.
Yeah.
You could put
it in a Shiny app.
So now, you're taking up a
very specific amount of space,
but you're still getting
that level of interactivity
with a scrollable table.
Exactly.
It's all about the divs.
Anything's [INAUDIBLE]
within divs.
So let me show you
the other thing I did,
which is the top part.
So what I did was I realized
I had to split it up.
Otherwise, it would
just not work.
It would just be terrible.
So what I've done is I
took a lot of the code that
was up here in this
main table, but I
took the parts that I needed.
So here's a little trick.
Here's a table with no rows,
but has the same columns.
You kind of need that, right?
Otherwise, you can't do any
of this stuff without it.
So I just copy this stuff,
made calls label change.
I [INAUDIBLE] the same.
I guess I didn't need it
above, because I'm obviously
just trying to hide it.
So let me show you the
thing where I hide it.
It's basically a--
oh, it's hiding here.
I do it on the next one.
There's more.
There's so many layers to this.
It's like an onion,
but just a huge onion.
So many layers to peel back.
So basically, this is the
same stuff as [INAUDIBLE]..
We need calls width
just like before.
I put this on there because
this is essentially Chrome
that goes on the outside.
So you need to have this.
You need to have a table font.
Need the alignment because that
affects the alignment of these
as well.
And then on the next
page, which is basically
sourcing in everything that came
before that, which is basically
those objects, I'm now
using HTML tools and divs
to create the different parts.
So they see three divs
inside one outer div.
The main thing is that
you just use tags div,
and then you put
your content in.
And the key way to get
your GT table content out
is just use asRawHtml
at the very end.
So this makes something--
but this dumps in those HTML,
and this is totally
cool with it.
This will just accept HTML.
I like that.
So you don't have to
write-- so let's unpack that
for a second.
You're saying you don't have
to write any HTML to get
HTML tools to recognize HTML.
Yeah, the key thing is
just outputting it as HTML.
If you just use [? GTPL ?]
object, right now,
it doesn't recognize it as
having HTML, so it's like,
what is this?
So if you just do
this, you're cool.
And another cool thing you
could do is, see the div?
We have a comma
[INAUDIBLE] content.
There's no argument there.
We can out a style argument.
And then you can use
this helper function
of HTML tools called CSS.
And it just helps you
write the different style
rules for the div, like
the inline styles, which
is kind of [INAUDIBLE]
set the overflow.
This is actually super key.
You need to have the
height of 500 pix
to make sure it
does this, and you
have to have these overflow
settings setup as auto
so it scrolls.
And then finally,
let me show you
the thing I did right here--
column labels hidden.
So we did that because we
took that NewsOrgs GT table
and just tweaked it a bit, so
it wouldn't show the column
labels again.
So if you scroll to
the very top of this,
it's not repeating this.
Is just the table
part, the bottom part,
and that's a little tweak I made
for the body, just making sure
the column labels are hidden.
I did the same thing--
you can just take the top.
So I called it NewsOrgsGTTop.
And then I basically just
made that hidden as well.
I added some source codes,
and then did the same thing,
ended it off with the raw HTML.
And then I got
this at the bottom
because that's in another div.
I didn't have to style that.
But then at the very bottom,
there's a style walk,
and this refers to the other
div, the very first one.
It can get kind of confusing
with all the commas everywhere.
But this is basically the
style for the entire div,
the outer div.
And basically, yeah,
I just made a border.
I put some background
color inside.
Pretty nice.
You can use this wherever.
It's just on color names.
Just for fun, just to remind me
that I still have this function
from-- it's in GT.
So I did a bit of that, made
the border thick enough.
And it looks pretty sweet.